zeytin ağacı ağır ve zahmetli büyüyen
ama bir o kadar da uzun ömürlü ve çok
dayanıklı O yüzden de mitolojideki adı
ölümsüz ağaç öyle bir ağaç ki
hititlerden iyonyalılara romalılardan
Türklere kadar pek çok dönem ve millete
tanıklık etmiş eşsiz bir doğa harikası
Bu bahsettiğim
yüzyıllarca bu insanlar Zeytinyağı ile
aydınlatmışlar karanlıklarını zeytin ve
Zeytinyağı ile doyurmuşlar karınlarını O
yüzden de Ege demek Akdeniz demek
alabildiğine sonsuz muazzam bir
maviliğin etrafına kök salmış Kurşuni
yeşil demek zeytin demek Biraz da
Benim de Çocukluğum 80'li yıllarda
Ege'nin küçük bir kentinde İşte bu
zeytin ağaçlarının arasında Koşuşturup
oynayarak o ilginç gövdelerini
hayranlıkla izleyerek Saklambaç oynarken
arkalarına gizlenerek
yapraklarının rengine çocuk aklımda her
defasında Hayret ederek geçtim tabi
zeytinin insanlık için bir armağan
olduğunu çok daha sonra öğrendim
adeta Yıllara meydan okuyan bu Muazzam
ağacın hikayesini meyvesinin faydalarını
tarihteki yerini ve önemini öğrendikçe
de doğanın Aslında bizlere karşı ne
kadar Cömert olduğunu gördüm ve bu beni
doğanın sundukları konusunda yepyeni
meraklara gitti acaba zeytin gibi Başka
ne tür mucizeleri vardı tabiat ananın
ortaokul ve lise yıllarıma geldiğimde
önce sosyal bilgiler Daha sonra da tarih
ve coğrafya derslerinde doğal
kaynakların
insanlığa doğanın sunduğu çevresel
etkenlerin ne kadar fazla ne kadar
çeşitli ne kadar Hayati olduğunu fark
etmeye başladım ve bu kaynaklarla ilgili
olarak da düşündüm acaba
çevremde ülkemde ve dünyada Bu
kaynaklardan daha başka neler vardı
Dolayısıyla araştırmaya okumaya çalıştım
ve öğrendiklerim doğayla olan aramdaki
bağı kuvvetlendirdi doğaya olan
hayranlığımda arttı ve meslek hayatım
bir tarih öğretmeni olarak mesleğimin
öğrencilerime Tarih biliminin
vazgeçilmez dinamikleri çerçevesinde
sadece milletlerin geçmişten bugüne
başından geçmiş olan olayları
anlatmaktan öğretmekten ibaret
olmadığına inandım hep Tarihsel süreç
devam ederken insanlar oradan oraya göç
ederken devletler kurulup yıkılırken
savaşlar ve anlaşmalarla tarihin seyri
sürekli değişirken anlamı ve önemi
değişmeyen ancak miktarı azalan el
değiştiren uğruna savaşılan kaynak
kavramının da her fırsatta altını
çizmeye çalıştım kaynakların değişiminin
ve bu değişimin tarihsel süreçleri nasıl
etkilediğinin göstermeye çalıştım
öğrencilerime tabi doğaya olan sevgimi
de aşılamaya gayret ettim
Biz insanlar aslında Çok da değerini
anlayamadığımız büyük bir servete
sahibiz
Yüzyıllardır bu hazine sayesinde insan
ayakta
bu hazine sayesinde devletler kurmuş
medeniyetler yaratmış icatlar yapmış
keşfettiklerini hep yenilerini katmış
aslında hep daha iyi standartlarda bir
hayat kurmak için olmuş tüm uğraşı ve bu
uğraşısı sırasında kendisine sunulan
kaynak olarak kendisine verilen ne varsa
çok da düşünmeden sınır tanımaz bir
iştahla harcamış ve bugün Hepimizin baş
etmek zorunda olduğu çözmek zorunda
olduğu sorunları da aslında insan kendi
elleriyle yaratmış
Peki nedir bu sorunlar doğal kaynakların
tükenişi iklim değişikliği hızla artan
şehirleşme oranı ve bu şehirlerde hızla
artan nüfus açlık yoksulluk finansal
krizler doğal türlerin yok oluşu salgın
hastalıklar ve Aslında Tüm bu sorunların
beraberinde getirdiği başka çeşit çeşit
büyük tehditler problemler
yalnız bize bir şeyler anlatmaya
çalışıyor Eğer Yüzyıllardır yaptığımız
gibi yaşamaya ürettiğimiz gibi üretmeye
tükettiğimiz gibi tüketmeye devam
edersek
hunharca isteklerle şekillendirdiğimiz
hayatı eğer aynı şekilde sürdürürsek
eğer biri kendi içerisinde kötücül olan
bu sorunların artacağını çeşitleneceğini
şiddetleneceğini söylüyor
Dünyamız tek Eğer bu dünyayı tüketirsek
başka bir gezegen daha yok Gidip
yerleşebileceğimiz bugün insanlık olarak
dünyanın bize sunduğu kaynakların
%50'sinden fazlasını kullanıyoruz ve 10
yıl sonra yanlış duymadınız Evet 10 yıl
sonra bu kaynaklar bize yetmeyecek
Peki ne yapabiliriz düşünelim Öncelikle
yine dünyaya daha yakından Bakalım eğer
iklim krizinin önüne geçmezsek şiddetli
hava olayları giderek etkisini
arttıracak bir yanda aşırı yağmurlar
aşırı Seller Diğer yanda aşırı
kuraklıklar Bunlar zamanla tarımı
bitirecek tarımın bitmesi demek açlık
demek ve biz iklim krizine neden olan en
büyük etken olan fosil yakıtları ısrarla
kullanmaya devam ediyoruz sanki
zorundaymışız ve başka hiçbir
seçeneğimiz yokmuş gibi Oysa ki
yenilenebilir enerji kaynaklarıyla da
pek de bir sürdürebiliriz hayatı bugün
dünyada Norveç İsveç Çin an Amerika gibi
ülkeler
yenilenebilir enerji kaynaklarını
kullanmak konusunda başı çekiyorlar ve
bizler de aslında hızla bu yolda
ilerlemeliyiz
iklim otoriteleri tarafından son
yıllarda yapılan araştırmalar ve ortaya
konan veriler son 200 yılda yani Sanayi
devriminden bu yana dünyanın ortalama
sıcaklığının bir nokta bir derece
arttığını ve bu sıcaklığın Mutlak
surette 2 santigrat derecenin altında
Hatta bir buçuk dereceye geçmeyecek
derecede tutulması gerektiğini öne
sürüyor Oysa ki yapılan başka
araştırmalarda insanlığın bu kaynakları
tüketici ve dünyayı kullanışına bakarak
bu sıcaklığın iki nokta dört dereceye
doğru hızla ilerlediğini gösteriyor Bu
aslında yakın zamanda ülkemizde de ve
çevre Ülkelerde de çok tanık olduğumuz
aşırı Seller yangınlar ve hatta dünyada
etkisini gözlemlediğimiz buzulların
erişi bunların etkileri konusunda
gerçekten bize bir alarm veriyor daha da
şiddetleneceğini gösteriyor ve
araştırmacılar
diyor ki yaşayacağımız iklim
felaketlerinin bu yaşadıklarını sadece
girizgahı niteliğinde
2020 yılının ilk 9 ayında kovid 19 için
tüm dünyadan hükümetler küresel yıllık
gelirin %14'ünü uyarıcı önlemler olarak
açıkladılar Peki bunu iklim krizi için
yapamaz mıyız Elbette ki yapabiliriz
yine ekonomistlerin ortaya koyduğu
istatistiklere baktığımızda Aslında
küresel yıllık gelirin sadece yüzde
ikisine denk gelen bir kısmı bir bütçe
iklim felaketlerinin çok da kolaylıkla
önüne geçebileceğimizi gösteriyor Tabii
bu konuda dikkatimiz ve bilincimiz de
çok önemli
Peki doğal kaynaklarımızı tüketiyoruz
doğal çevremizi korumuyoruz doğal canlı
türleri gitgide azalıyor Bu da tabii ki
iklim krizini çok etkiliyor Bu Dünyanın
dengesini değiştirmeye başladı hem de
çok hızlı bir şekilde
şu ana kadar anlattıklarımla moralinizi
bozmak istemezdim ancak görmeliyiz
aynadan yansıyanlara bakmalıyız ve bu
yansımayı değiştirmeliyiz
ne olacak nasıl çözülecek sorunlar nasıl
olacak Dünyanın değişimi nedir değişmek
ve dönüşmek nasıl olur dünyayı
değiştirmek bir anda oğlu veren mucizevi
bir şey midir değişim yoksa zaman
içerisinde adım adım mı gerçekleşir
mesafelere yenilir mi değiştirmek
isteyeceklerin yoksa sınır tanımaz bir
olgu mudur
bir yanda akıl almaz yenilikler bilimsel
gelişmeler günlük hayatımızı hızla
değiştiren olaylar varken Aslında özünü
kaybeden ve günlük hayatımıza bir tehdit
olarak uzanan da çok fazla şey var
değişimi ileriye doğru götürürken acaba
daha güzel bir dünya bırakmak için
gelecek nesillere acaba bu sorunları
çözmek için bize düşenler neler çok şey
yapabiliriz hem de çok şey önce
sorunları görmek ve sorumluluk duymakla
başlayabiliriz yani farkına varmakla
başlayabiliriz
Ben birey olarak biz toplum olarak acaba
bu sorunlar konusunda neler yapabiliriz
bize düşenlerle diyerek yola çıkabiliriz
Örneğin plastik poşetler yerine bez
çantalar plastik Şişeler yerine cam
Şişeler kullanmak çevre ile ilgili
sorunları çözmeye yeter mi çok yakından
takip ettiğiniz bir markanın ya da bir
sivil toplum örgütünün hafta sonu
düzenlediği çöp toplama etkinliğine
katılmanız doğa ve çevre ile ilgili
sorunları çözmekte doğaya olan zararları
engellemekte ne kadar işe yarar ne kadar
katkı sağlar Elinizde pankartlarla bir
çevre yürüyüşüne katılmak ya da
çalışmalarını çok yakından takip
ettiğiniz bir dernek veya vakfa 50
aralıklarla bağışlarda bulunmak Acaba
sürdürülebilirliğe ne oranda katkı
sağlar
Elbette ki hiçbir boş uğraşlar değil ama
bizim çok daha kritik adımlar atmamız
gerekiyor
Öncelikle yaşam tarzımızı ve
alışkanlıklarımızı değiştirmemiz lazım
örneğin; ortaya çıkardığımız atık
miktarını azaltmak
israfı önlemek Elimizde olan tüm doğal
kaynaklarımızı tasarruflu kullanmak
mesela
düşünün yiyecek alışverişinizi eve
aldığınız her şeyi bozulmadan çürümeden
tüketebiliyor musunuz kıyafet
alışverişinizi düşünün mesela gerçekten
ihtiyacınız olduğu için mi yoksa rengini
modelini desenini beğendiğiniz için mi
kıyafet alıyorsunuz
Bilgisayarınızı kullanmadığınızda
tamamen Kapatıyor musunuz yoksa Uyku
moduna mı alıyorsunuz evde ofiste
çalıştığınız iş yerinizde atıklarınızı
düşünün geri dönüşüme Uygun olabilecek
atıkları ayrıştırıyor musunuz yoksa
hepsini Aynı çöp kutusuna mı atıyorsunuz
yine kullandığınız temizlik
malzemelerinize bir bakın acaba Doğa
dostu mu yoksa suyu kirleten cinsten mi
Bunların hepsi günlük hayatımızda çok
kolayca Aslında
gerçekleştirebileceğimiz dikkat
edebileceğimiz binlerce adımdan sadece
birkaç tanesi Çok mu zor Hayır çok kolay
ama hepimiz yaptığımızda hepimiz buna
alışkanlığa dönüştürdüğümüzde bir yaşam
tarzı haline getirdiğimizde
doğaya katkısı
sürdürülebilirliğe katkısı müthiş o
zaman ikinci önemli adımımız bilinçli
olmak ve farkındalığımızı alışkanlıklara
dönüştürmek olmalı
2015 yılında dünyada İnsanlık için iki
tane çok önemli adım atıldı bunlardan
bir tanesi birleşmiş milletlerin küresel
Kalkınma hedeflerini ortaya koyuşu
diğeri de çok uzun süren görüşmeler
sonucunda kabul edilen ve devletler için
yasal bağlayıcılığı da olan Paris
Anlaşması bu iki gelişme doğrultusunda
da dünya devletlerine Hedef olarak
konulan tarih 2030 ve şu anda dünyadan
birçok devlet hızla bu konuda
Politikalar üretmeye bu devletlerin
bünyesindeki kurum kuruluş oluşum ve
örgütler buna yönelik kampanyalar
projeler uygulamalarla dünyayı
kurtarmaya çalışıyor
O zaman biz de çevremizde bu tür
kampanyalara projelere destek
verebiliriz Biz de çözümün bütünün büyük
tablonun bir parçası olabiliriz Bu da
üçüncü adımımız olsun
Evet dünyayı kurtarmak için
yapılabilecek Tabii ki çok şey var
Bunlar çok kritik adımlar ama bir yandan
da tabii şunu söylemek istiyorum değişim
Gerçekten hepimiz için mümkün insanın
elinde kalbinde aklında ve becerisinde
hepsini olanak var peki
biz öğretmenler ve eğitimin bu
değişimdeki rolü bir öğretmenin sadece
tek görevinin Aslında mesleğindeki alan
bilgisini öğrencilerine aktarmak
olmadığını başta da söylemiştim
Hayati görevleri
rol model olduğu davranışlar ve Aslında
saymakla bitmeyecek kadar fazlaca değer
var bir öğretmenin öğrencilerine tuttuğu
ışıktan o zaman değişim ve dönüşümde de
biz öğretmenlerin ve eğitimin gerçekten
çok büyük katkısı olmalı
Bugün dokunduğumuz her öğrencimize
Okuldan taşıp eve evden taşıp topluma
yansıyacak olan bilinci vermeliyiz bu
bilinçli hareket etmeyi Doğal kaynakları
korumayı bunların gerekliliğini onlara
öğretmeliyiz çocuklarla ve gençlerle
çalışmalıyız Onlarla bu değişimi
güçlendirmeliyiz onlardan başlayıp
topluma ve dünyaya yayılan bir dalga
yaratmalıyız Tabii Aslında sadece Doğa
konusunda çevre konusunda ve kaynaklar
konusunda değil sürdürülebilir kalkınma
hedeflerinin küresel boyutta anlaşılması
uygulanabilmesi özümsene bilmesi için de
bu Sürdürülebilir bir dünyaya nasıl
ulaşılacağının adımlarının en iyi
şekilde öğrenebilmesi için de eğitimin
ve öğretmenlerin rolü çok kıymetli
bugün bilginin arttığı çok hızla yayıldı
teknolojinin hızla geliştiği ve bir
yandan yaşam tarzlarının kültürlerin çok
hızlı bir şekilde farklı formlara
evrildiği ama anlamın azaldığı bir
dünyada yaşıyoruz o zaman Bizler
değişimi dünyaya hayata her alanda anlam
katmak için Hedef seçelim
değişimi özü korumak için Hedef seçelim
dünyaya olan Vefa borcumuzu ödemek için
çocuklarımıza gençlerimize çok daha
yaşanılır güzel
Sürdürülebilir bir dünya bırakmak için
seçelim
Dünyamız çok cömert gerçekten bize
sunduklarıyla onu korumamız lazım
değişim dünyanın ihtiyacı olan şey şu
anda duyalım dünyayı ertelemeyelim
sorunlara karşı sırtımızı dönmeyelim hep
birlikte olalım önce kendi neslimizi
sonra da gelecek nesilleri kurtaralım
değişim biz olalım Haydi gelin değişim
bizimle başlasın Çünkü gelecek bizim
Dünya Bizim
değişimelerimizde Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]